hello welcome to a brand new episode of
not too deep I'm grace Helbig this is a
very scary exciting episode because we
have Nick Hamilton the bully from it and
it too and turns out he is really good
at acting because he's the gang
sweetheart we talk all about the making
of those films we talk about Australia
because guess what he's Australian he
was acting with the American accent you
guys he's better than all of us and he's
got a really cute dog we talked all
about it on this episode of not too deep
in the Hamilton turn those great ideas
into reality with Squarespace they make
it easier than ever to launch your
passion project with your showcasing
your work or selling products of any
kind they have beautiful templates and
the ability to customize just about
anything so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself but if
you do get stuck they have a 24/7
award-winning customer support that's
there to help you out so head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% of
your first purchase of a website or
domain Nick thank you for being here
thank you for having me Nicholas Nick
which do you prefer Oh Nick my mom calls
me Nicholas your mom cause it is formal
yeah she's formal you're hard Australian
yeah mom maestra mu M om right right
yeah you're so you're from Australia yes
your whole family's back there do they
come overseas here my mom does a lot a
lot she comes she tries to come almost
every like three months which is from
the other side of the world that's a lot
yeah so she never adjusts to like any
time no no no she's always on like
holidays and stuff too so she's just
constantly around the world I don't know
what is her life the crazy crazy
I want that she came she came for the it
to premiere which was two weeks ago and
she's already talking about coming end
of next month oh really it's just like
that's just it's it's a lot of bum but
it was great
it's okay so let's jump into it okay
okay I haven't seen it - oh I'm very
sorry because seeing it one was a lot
had to be very
I am very coached by Elliott Morgan to
watch this I hey I get scared at like
literally if we have this painting of
this Bumble baby if I look at it my god
yeah see if I look at that without
remembering that it's there I'm
terrified so that level of immediate
fear doesn't really work out for those
kinds of movies but I gave him the
benefit of doubt it was great I just
didn't sleep for the rest of the night
fair another dice that's fine oh there
yeah so okay let's talk about how this
started you we've been acting for years
now yeah started when I was 11
you started Wow okay and you're starting
acting in Australia or you can tell us
yeah so I started did like a school play
when I was great I try to tell no one
that you do actual research for it no no
God no no I was 11 I didn't give a [ __ ]
that's why was because I played an Elvis
impersonator in a talent show in a
musical so as a bit Wow like I jumped oh
I hesitated Lee I hesitated when I was
auditioning because I was just like yeah
that's lame yeah there's an audition for
the part with the least lines and they
gave me Elvis was like it's at least
line to be also have to sing a full song
so for the plate did a full lip-syncing
to another guy singing a novice not even
a novice song it was like Jesus is about
a friend of mine pretending to play the
guitar with my two buddies like I jumped
off the stage at some point and like
high-five the audience and was it was
completely unplanned and I just like
fell in love with that so I yeah I
joined an Australian agent yeah where I
live and yeah I got a few jobs with her
short films got my first TV role of her
and one of the short films I did I
managed to somehow win an award for it
and that's my bigger agent that I have
now in Australia recognise that so you
didn't do like any training really kind
of a little bit just did some workshop
swim it was mainly kind of just jumping
into
my first audition was for a spin-off of
h2o just add water which is like a
mermaid show back in Australia which is
you know I'm the vine where they like
clear yeah that's that's from that so
it's from that show and that's we did a
spin-off of that called Mako mermaids
sure and I was in one of the episodes of
that and that was my first first ever
audition and I managed to get it just
kind of went from there and yeah I did a
little bit of training but not much okay
so then when do you come to the u.s.
that was after so I got my first film
with my bigger agents my first American
film with her got some US reps got a
couple jobs one of them being it one
that you can't just drop that like
that's a casual like thing that happens
for everyone that has a fantasy of
moving to Hollywood very very okay let's
talk about the audition process for it
huh auditioning in and of itself sucks
no I hate it yeah if I met anyone that
loved did I be like you're a psycho I'm
saying yeah the what's the audition
process like well this one that wasn't
really it was one audition okay and I
was a self-type I sent in I was visiting
my brother who was living in the UK at
the time and we just landed in London
and we were in this like airport hotel
we were jet-lagged and I got this email
when I was like waking up at 3 a.m. that
local times and that I had to do an
urgent audition for a Stephen King
picture yeah and casual headlines yeah
yeah so I did I did I was pissed about
it because I was so tired and jet-lagged
so I set up my iPhone on top of two
suitcases on top of a desk in this hotel
yeah that's how I make all my usually
the only way to do it but then yeah did
like two takes and sent both of them off
because I couldn't be bothered to pick
which one sure and I said I'm going back
to sleep and did that holiday and go
back home and I was unpacking and got
the roll that's which is just never
happened never happens which is so no it
just shows how much I mean Andy the
director he's a he's a visionary in his
genius he can see what's gonna happen
cuz I I watch
that audition literally yesterday yeah
that's it back and I was like that's a
sheet old issue I mean thank you very
much but you're inside now you need to
like just wake up at 3:00 a.m. for all
of your auditions now maybe that tired
energy they saw something in you but
that's so did you have any familiarity
with it before oh really
no I mean I was at audition for a couple
Stephen King projects beforehand like
they were doing like an standby meet
riemeck or something that never got made
but it was always kind of like they were
trying to do a lot of Stephen King stuff
around that and I just done the The Dark
Tower which is another stinking property
so I just done a small role in that
after not getting the lead okay and then
I go back and manage to get it so I was
like it was kind of I was on my radar
but it was never really something I was
ever really interested in because I hate
horror movies
I hate really hate scary things do you
yeah I'm a wuss so okay we can relate on
that but uh so how do you you're going
in you're playing your role is like very
emotionally intense right so how do you
prep for that is punching pillows and I
honestly don't know it's like kind of
when you're preparing for something like
that you just kind of have to hope it's
inside of you yeah when you have to play
just a psychopath who is unrelenting and
and doesn't do anything good yeah and
you get the I mean you get to it's fun I
think it's fun of them being able to
play the good guy because you get to do
you get overact that's called good
acting yeah it's great I've know you now
and like you're a very nice human being
so you are truly acting in this so it
must feel like this is not really me
right I'm lucky I like tapping into
something you know visceral yeah I don't
know what I think everyone has it must
have like a little bit of something like
that inside them I don't know if it's
easier for people who actually dicks in
real life
yeah but yeah I know for some reason it
just came natural for me to be able to
just like cackle and like this probably
isn't a good thing really easily
should I be concerned for my emotional
growth no I'm listening to a podcast
about the Zodiac killer so it's like
everyone everyone has that little bit of
I'm sure if I put you in front of a
camera and said good just go nuts you'll
be able to do it yeah if you told me the
whole girl Housewives franchise has been
cancelled indefinitely I think I could
access that everyone needs that little
thing in their bread yeah okay so how
was shooting then you're going on set
you're meeting everyone everyone's of
the same age group which must be very
cool and also like intimidating that you
guys all have to take on this like huge
endeavor yeah I mean everyone I mean it
helps that asset especially the first
movie set was just phenomenal when
everyone was we shot in Toronto so
everyone's Canadian Oh lovely yeah it's
very very nice and all the all the kids
just like we became best friends right
away and then just very stand-up guys
and they've continued to be that way
even through all this sort of Fame
overnight all the kids it was cool to be
kind of an outsider to that to watch I
mean I have a mullet in so it's kind of
no one really kind of sees me as that
but there's seven kids that's their life
that's kind of there that now they can
branch off yeah but they'll be known as
that person from its yeah so it was
really cool to I mean it's the same
thing we saw Finn the first season of
stranger things came out while we were
filming in oh yeah there was no one and
then everyone open it literally crazy
that's the same thing with the kids
though it was as soon as the movie came
out in theaters it was just hanging out
with them just became kind of a lot but
yeah throughout that they've maintained
the same dignity and humility that they
had from the beginning which is awesome
that's so rare especially in child
actors oh yeah 100% so it was the mullet
real know I'm Alex fake okay exactly
it's a piece so Andy the director well
from the beginnings of the mullet I'd
like to I like to say
but I'd like to I'd like to think that
the mullet is my idea
oh yeah because I came I was walking
around set and I heard some guys I think
of in the prosthetic Straley are talking
about what they were gonna do with my
hair and I was like oh yeah heard
they're gonna put a mullet on you I was
like oh I had no idea that sounds like a
great idea so I went to the hair trail I
was like so I heard you're putting a
mullet on me and they said we haven't
heard anything about this but that's a
great idea I looked at photos of the
stuff that we've done before the mullet
and it's nowhere near as crazy so I
worked it perfectly little piece it's
like a little peso I had very long hair
for me
and it's just like it clicks onto the
back of my head basically it was like
little like oh hell there's a scene in
the second one which I'm sure I can talk
about I was like a little shot where I
come out and I come out of some water
and I'm like my head's back and so the
wig was basically dangling in the water
so it's kinda like snapping off like red
macaws on my scalp off my head when I
was screaming so I just like get up and
like scream
beauty is pain the beauty is pain and it
was screaming for real that's fun as
someone that's had hair extensions many
times in my life that's pointless me
talking to someone who does this all the
time and saying oh it hurts so much I
did it for three months no you got paid
to wear that no that's sewn so you're
going and you're making this movie
you're wearing your hairpiece you're
doing all this and then how long was it
from wrapping to the movie coming out we
wrapped about that's not probably a year
before the movie came out and so you're
just sitting now on this thing wondering
like will this come out and how will it
be received like when it first came out
did you it was it shocking was it like
holy [ __ ]
yeah I mean I think we always thought we
gauged I went to a party in LA during
the filming of it and I got asked on the
carpet about it and that was the first
time I'd been on a movie where people
actually gave a [ __ ] about it before it
came out yeah so that was cool to me
that was just like how people actually
care about this and there was a few like
Facebook fan pages that popped up before
the movie so and Instagram fan pages
popped up before the movie came out so
we kind of knew that people were going
to see it right but it came out and it
was you can't 123 million domestic
opening which is the biggest opening for
an r-rated process which is just you
can't yeah process that at all seen us
and all the kids as I said all the kids
just went bonkers overnight to 300 K
followers over not just like that's so
how do you handle that then like now cuz
you it's very cool that all we have like
these Venn diagrams of like friends and
people that were into that crossover
that like you've been like a you know
rhett and Link fan and you've watched
Internet and like the valley folk and
all those guys like the see you're
seeing and watching all these people on
the internet then all of a sudden like
now you're in it that's the very cool
part of my job is that to be in a movie
especially not have a huge part in a
very big movie yeah that's sure you
don't get all the the huge 1 to 2
million followers which is it's like
it's just you get all the the things
that you've wanted over a lot of your
life I get to be on good mythical
morning which is insane exactly the
exact same people I'm always like every
time I've been around them I'm always
waiting for like the facade to come down
and for them to like be really who they
are and they're exactly the exact same
people yeah that's the same thing to
like as if you watch good mythical
morning the crew is like the cast doors
yeah so even getting like the the
producers introduced me to rhett and
Link I was just like this is not like
I'm in this play house I have only seen
through a screen right so strange
yeah even like meeting Steve Steve
Zaragoza yeah that was through Steve
through fin really so Finn was a
SourceFed fan yeah and then he met Steve
just cuz he's in wolfhard
also like Steve Zaragoza is like a very
bizarre conduit to so many different
people in the universe everyone it blows
my mind that he is like the link between
so many random groups of people types of
people yeah
but that's so Finn met him and then at
the it one premiere okay he introduced
me to Steve Kerr Steve came yeah and
then yeah just throughout that I mean we
while we were shooting it - in September
of last year he and the rest of the
valley folk came to Toronto for like an
event so we all hang out then that's how
I met the valley folk and been very good
friends with those guys ever since and
it's just go and that's connected me to
weird sort of internet route so thing I
mean I've used to fall asleep to not do
deep which is keep saying to all my
friends just like this isn't real but
that's the cool thing like hearing that
you like get thrust into this like weird
limelight sit you internet so [ __ ]
weird and let you get thrust into it
overnight but you're still like a very
grounded like it's a testament to all of
your guys's characters and I'm sure you
guys [ __ ] with each other keep each
other grounded and Iceland give each
other perspective on things like
especially like when did you guys find
out that the second one was happening we
kind of always knew there was always
we'd sign an option at the start of the
first movie that I think I'm gonna do
the second one is two changes of those
other when if the movie didn't make
enough money we wouldn't do it right as
soon as we realized that there was hype
around the first one we would say all
come back here we go I was always like
because it was the same crew for the
majority of the same crew for the for
the second movie so we left the first
movies like oh this is sad but I'll see
you in two years yeah yeah it was crazy
did anyone have weird puberty I'm sure
jack Jack Dillon grayza who is I think
they were like it would've been 1213
when they first shot it yeah he's 1516
now and he's his voice has dropped seven
octaves and he's just like crazy tall
it's just there's a lot of I mean Finn
yeah Finn is really growing but yeah I
mean it's cool to see all of them on the
grow in that sense but just grow as
human beings and only I mean you'd
expect Finn out of all of them to be the
most self-centered she's just not even
close to it yeah none of them have even
an ounce of that in them which is
astonishing to me that's very cool
testament to everyone around us to like
all their families and parents and their
moms and dads have been around with him
from the start of the first one my mom
and dad have been around for the start
of the first one so it's
good foundations you guys got good
foundations do you guys goop's and
spoofs on set you guys it's pranking
each other really unset I mean it was
just so what we have a group shot still
now on Instagram and snapchat that's
just is just that's garbage hacked or
something and we would just like we need
to delete it wants them because we're
just like it's just it was like okay no
crazy stuff in this one but it's just
absolutely can't speak a full sentence
without going okay where's the dog the
dog is at home currently shoot I left
her with with the cleanup back home
how long have you had but what's her
name now her name's not no okay
what type of dog she looks like a cute
little scrunchy thing ya know she's a
she's a Pomeranian cross I think it's a
Papillon Papillon Iranian terrier
crossed Pomeranian now she looks like a
fox I love her more than most people in
this world I get that so how long have
you had her I've had her just after my
birthday which probably three months
little baby little baby but she was four
and a bit when I go to okay um she was
adopted a foreign place called
Vanderpump look as someone that watches
all the Real Housewives and Vanderpump
rules when I saw that you tagged that as
your location with like welcome to my
new baby I was like I literally wrote
down from Vanderpump da wait so how what
how'd this happen it's a great place in
[Music]
its use it's a big pink building because
of course it is miss it and I loved it
so much I went I still haven't been
there I've only seen because they're the
little Tanya's fluffs but yeah so I went
there
I was I went there a couple times with
friends just to see dogs because I
didn't have a dog I was just like it's
better than therapy exactly
but then I went sometime I think it was
like a wake after my birthday with one
of my friends and Nala was kind of just
there I was like I came to see dogs and
Nala was there and she was she was named
Zoe at that point okay she was sort of
looking at me and I patted her and left
and there was this mother and daughter
behind me who went basically in line to
chat to Nala uh-huh
but now I kept looking at me just like
so I'm getting this dog yeah I can't I
can't no you can't not yeah and I mean
my building is everyone has a dog yeah
so it's great oh that's so great
connection forms it's undeniable the
best dog in the world cuz that's like
she was abused like from it with a
parents which is insane cuz I mean one
she's cute came here but with that cute
of a dog and she has actually knows how
to sit already she's potty-trained like
how could you hate that dog yeah what
are you doing she's doing everything
perfectly in the what are you doing
yeah great well okay you will have to
come back and then you will bring
knowledge bring no no it's okay
we I mean as I would get distracted this
would be a two hour podcast which it
should just soon okay let me get back I
have more questions for you we'll be
right back with more not your deep
[Music]
support for today's show comes from our
dear friends over at Squarespace turn
your dream into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project are
you looking to start a new business
showcase your work published content
sell products or more Squarespace is the
tool for you they have beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks so
you can easily make a beautiful website
by yourself
plus they're powerful ecommerce
functionality lets you sell anything
online and they have analytics that help
grow your site in real time everything
is optimized for mobile right out of the
box so there's nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you'll get the help that you need
with squarespace's 24/7 award-winning
customer support Squarespace empowers
millions of people from designers to
lawyers artists to gamers even
restaurants and gyms to turn great ideas
into something real so head the
squarespace.com / grace for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code grace to save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
that squarespace.com / grace offer code
grace Rebecca with more not too deep as
you probably already showed should know
ok so chapter 2 how was the filming
different if at all is it just you guys
all kind of know you're excited there's
like momentum there's I yeah I mean
there's more pressure yes I mean there's
more I mean there was more adults on set
it was more completely different car
specs so it was like still had all the
kids and there were there a lot only
film like three days but I was in
Toronto for probably four or five weeks
in total oh wow I'm just could've had my
shooting shooting that was pressure it
was cool I got to be there every day and
see Bill Hader be hilarious every single
second can imagine it's just so great
and like seeing my older counterpart go
crazy and I mean all the kids do their
same characters that everyone loves now
it's really cool it's really cool to see
it was very casual but I think it was
there was kind of just a general
knowledge that's we have to get this one
right yeah because the first one there
was there was pressure but it was like
if we don't get it right
some people will see it and then it
would kind of just fade up and do it
into existence but there's now there's
expectation everyone will say this one
whether it's good or bad yeah yeah it's
just like we have to make this good and
we did but that's awesome so in in real
life do people come up to you and treat
you as if they believe that you are
truly a bully it's the funny thing I've
always known as I mean I'm not
recognized much but whenever I am it's
always that kind of trepidation can I
get a it's fine if you don't want it but
I kind of what can I get a photo please
sweet and also like you can sure feel
people like noticing you and being like
at a distance a lot of people do this
all my friend because I never notice if
it's all my family and friends when I'm
around them they go like a shopping
center yeah they're always like do you
know is that a girl looking at you and
being too scared to go to was like I
didn't whenever i cuz if I saw it I'd go
up to them and say you know please don't
be scared of me like any 19 year old boy
should be doing to girls in the mall
going please don't be scared me but that
must be so fun and funny to be like I
truly am a nice person
please I think I'm a nice person please
like me how has it been now you're going
you're doing these premieres you're
going to like award shows you're doing
[ __ ] like that like have you come in to
have you met anyone that's like you're
fangirling out about it's all the
internet people I was always that kid
when I was from ten ten years old
onwards it was always YouTube I would
always watch YouTube every afternoon
after school every night just fell
asleep
so was always I mean rhettandlink was a
huge one obviously God have I met but
it's just it's all like I was at the the
SAG Awards in 2017 mm-hmm for another
movie I did and I met Meryl Streep and
that was awesome but for some reason I
was way most awestruck by like Steve
okay so do you still watch YouTube now
hmm okay who do you keep up with give me
some recommendation oh I watch a lot of
still watch just good mythical morning
every morning yeah they're great
I watched a lot of Valley folk stuff
that was just I watch a lot of visual
podcasts like just I mean I listened to
a lot of pop cut pork has to fall asleep
and on road trips and stuff but it's a
lot of the time I'll just put like an
hour-long podcast on my YouTube and just
kind of sit my phone and watch that sort
of absent-mindedly
stuff like this stuff like dumb it
dynamic banter no
yeah have you have you met the Mike
Falzone I've met my first among I want
to bottle his laughter and just sprayed
on me like perfume every day him and
Steve just together a perfect do it yeah
that's why I love I was on a road trip
to Utah recently and it's put on like
ten episodes of dynamic banter and just
cracked up the whole way there so silly
funny that's so clever yes ingenious
boys truly dynamic banter yes well okay
let's say you had to win a fight for 10
million dollars who do you think you'd
have a better chance against Steve
Zaragoza Elliott Morgan Mike Falzone oh
I was gonna if it was gonna be Steven
and Mike I'd say Steve because Steve
wouldn't want to hurt me like if that
was up for Elliott he would some reason
go into like a fighting stance like bro
I have to do this like talk his way out
of why you should give him the money
without fighting him we can stand here
and we can just kind of time it out yeah
or we can stand here and showcase all of
our deep-seated daddy issues if you want
to whereas Mike Falzone I feel like
would actually put up a Massachusetts
thank you if any of them actually
genuinely fought me I wouldn't be able
to win but I think Steve would just kind
of refuse to fight me so I'd pick Steve
yeah I think I would do the same right
okay so you can sing hmm hold it you
dabble I double so are there any like
musicals you'd want to be a part of oh
that's a good question um are you
interested in that world
I never specially with this whole you
know live musical situation that happens
all the time
I mean I mean obviously I think Hugh
Jackman is a huge kind of instance it's
the same dance I can do everything but
dance I think well he's not everything
that's a stretch
I could do a tiny amount of things in
one of the amount and one of the things
I can't do is dance you're not gonna be
on the next season of Dancing with the
Stars humiliate myself and everyone that
is related to me you know it's always
good to realize our boundaries yeah you
have to know yeah you have to know but I
mean I don't really watch a lot of
Broadway stuff I went and saw come from
a way have you seen that nope so great
about the people in Newfoundland I think
you pronounce it as like greatly yeah
but it's about those people who after
9/11 they brought down a lot of planes
from the skies and that take emergency
landings and crazy sports so
Newfoundland was like there's a town in
Newfoundland that had like population
100 and overnight because of 9/11 that
day they had like 10,000 because all the
planes at the lands yeah there so that
was really cool like it was just it's
like a very funny musical about how
these people win from logic with these
funny accents okay so it's light-hearted
yeah it's very very funny and very yeah
it's all very it's very diverse because
everyone from around the world landing
in Newfoundland of this like like we
live here because we don't want very
funny I saw that very recently but um I
don't really watch many I mean dear
vannhansen it would kind of suit me I
guess that make sense do you like doing
I love solving musical that's me there
you go there you go put it manifest okay
Danger Close hmm tell us about this
agenda close is an Australian movie that
I did yeah recently that came out in
August in Australia coming out November
8th here cool in theaters on digital on
DVD okay and VHS I'm sure yeah I get it
where you can get but it's it's about
the only prominence Australian battle in
the Vietnam War that the most prominent
where 100 Australian guys aged like 19
to 22 went up against an estimated force
of about wow like mm maybe okay
something in the thousands just the odd
we're not in there and it's the story of
that battle and the the bonds between
those boys and I play play private no
Grimes who's still alive today which is
quite whoa it was a bit of a pressure
Wow
yeah did you did you talk to him no he
lives in New Zealand so there was a lot
of the boys who we actually play in the
movie who came to set who were still
alive because it only happened in the
sixties Wow
whenever the Vietnam War was so it's
very like that's all the boys that came
to set were very like I remember this
happening Wow 10 grams you couldn't come
couldn't couldn't make it but there's
plenty of photos of like what he did and
he was apparently just a scoundrel and
mm-hmm yeah it was a fun shoot it was
all I was like 10 hour a day is filled
with mud and fake rain and in your full
sort of army gear and it was good fun
there's just a ton of like 20 main cast
like blokes just we do this 10 hour
shoot and then go shower and have a
three beers never filmed in the Gold
Coast in Australia so then 5 a.m. we
wake up and go do it again so yeah it
was great
that sounds actually like a very cool
experience and get cold rain sure and
fake and having to because that we
didn't have any blanks in the guns so
we'd just be kind of just moving her
arms so it's just like I mean and every
time we did it it was like we'd stop
complaining them realize that what
actually happened uh-huh
this is like we can't complain we're
doing yeah we're not being shot up yeah
it was a great great experience just
filled with a lot of lovely boys who
live here too in LA so it's just yeah
all the boys keep in contact with what
do you miss the most about Australia um
probably the people I mean it's the
people that are you guys are very nice
very nice people I guess I mean that's I
live in a very I used to live in a very
very pretty part of the world called
Byron Bay yeah she's right on the on the
beach basically on the on the east coast
of Australia it's just just beaches and
green and blue
everywhere and stunning so picturesque
and you take that for granted until you
move out here and you're in the city and
yeah I mean if you don't live in Santa
Monica you're done for and when you fly
in you see that thick coat of fog it
wraps you completely but yeah the people
all my friends and family that I that I
left I think said truly I moved up here
when I was 18 alone Wow I got my
two-bedroom apartment so it can feel
quite lonely sometimes yeah what was
that like that's so scary yes I mean
that's it was that was some rough times
I mean genuinely that was to not get too
deep it was correct it was that's so
tired there were some people there who
like there was a it was a week there
that had a rough time it was a week
where I didn't speak to someone I knew
personally Wow using my voice I was I
had to go to like Starbucks and get a
coffee come back home and then just hang
it there all there
that was a week yeah yeah it was tough
and that was before I reached out to
Steve and Pat another one my friends
here was just like very very close
friends of mine and I count them dearly
because it takes friends to make this
town worth it a hundred percent as
someone that's worked on the internet I
can i like relate to that wholeheartedly
that yeah there's times there I'm like
oh the only thing I've talked to you
today is a camera this isn't that
doesn't cause any I mean you're sitting
in your because I don't think I had a
couch at this point during this week
okay so it's just like a bed and my
bedroom was made and nothing else so I'd
sit in the bed all day which is like
that's not look I still do that right
this makes you I think sitting in a cat
and a couch is kind of more normal human
and you can actually kind of have to get
dressed and yeah sit down on the couch
but sitting in bed you can kind of just
there's no reason to go anywhere else no
yeah it is yeah it's very lonely and got
like that and that's I found a couple
friends in different states that I visit
a lot more now that's that's very nice
what's the weirdest thing about the u.s.
to you what was like that was because
you you got a new car right I did get me
I got a I hadn't driven on the right
side of the road
ever yeah what what's that like cuz I
haven't driven I've been in Australia a
couple times but I refused to drive I
one time tried it once and I was like
nope I forget how everything works
I cannot compute this I guess I mean I
had a a tastic car which we call manual
cars um at a stick back in Australia
uh-huh
so that was kind of it was easy to go
from at least I didn't have to go full
extreme in Australia to full extreme
driving stick on the right side of the
road here I haven't automatic car yeah
that's lovely
I put the cruise control on and that's
great but ya know it's it was tough I
failed my first driving tests because I
didn't take any lessons my first lesson
was on the way to like I had that kind
of lesson to take you to the driving
test and then they do the test and their
Drive you home oh I don't know that this
service exists it's kind of it is it's a
driving test but instead of driving
around your area they drive from your
home to the driving tests yeah
so I did that that was my first time
driving on the right side of the road
was driving to my driving test so of
course I failed
I was trying that's the the hardest
thing about driving on this side is
basically all the rules is when you're
driving when you turn left at a light
yeah you can pull ahead when the light
goes green yeah and then turn left yeah
in Australia that's illegal
because you have to have to wait behind
that line until it's safe to go yeah you
can creep you creep into the I did that
the first time because I knew that was
kind of a rule so we did that during my
test was the first left turn had to do
and I was like okay oh wait oh wait oh
wait oh wait oh wait and I was about to
pull out and she's like car okay wait
wait oh wait oh wait oh wait and that
pull that pedestrian okay sort of failed
oh yes you have passed my second time
though and I'd only done those two tests
two lessons before that so I'm I think
I believe in you I mean I if you tried
to make me take a driving test right now
I would get to us no I couldn't unfair
right now you know I've been driving for
nine months now no okay we're gonna take
one last break when we get back we got
all these Twitter questions for you
we'll be right back with 108 the
holidays are coming and that means a lot
of new stuff will be piling up under the
tree so why not make some space for it
all by selling the stuff you don't use
anymore
I'm Akari Macari is the selling app that
makes selling your stuff fast and easy
just go through your home and find all
that good stuff that you don't use
anymore like the phone in that drawer or
the jeans that you only wore once or
that handbag the tiding behind the other
stuff you don't use you take a few pics
you add a description and boom your item
is connected to millions of buyers it's
super easy
Macari even emails you a shipping label
when it sells you can even use Macari to
buy gifts too with millions of sellers
you never know what treasures you'll
find the app has over 500,000 reviews on
the App Store with an average 4.8 star
rating so why not give it a try finally
an app that makes you money
check out Macari and lighten this load
this holiday season that's em e are C a
are I merc re the selling app to deep as
the creators of clean beauty Bare
Minerals is driven by a philosophy the
makeup and skin care should make your
skin better not just better looking
that's why their best-selling original
foundation is made with only five
ingredients all minerals what a shock
for bare minerals to be clean without
compromise means good for skin formulas
with proven performance upgrade to clean
beauty products use the foundation
finder at bare minerals calm to find
your perfect match and get 20% off when
you use the promo code not too deep bare
minerals the power of good okay
Nick you know what I'm about to ask you
the two questions that I ask every
single guest that is on the podcast and
the first question is who alive or dead
would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti act as a fascinating thing is
that I knew I've known from when I was
15 listen let me think
cold spaghetti because I've always
thought I mean a lot of people can they
construe it as either positive or
negative very it's very subjective and
it also can change day to day like this
can be your answer for today but you
might have a different answer tomorrow
Justin Trudeau
oh there's of his whole he didn't he did
a racist thing so I was just like I'd be
more like it instead of like instead of
like a hit it'll be kind of just like oh
you silly [ __ ] you're protesting no oh
no that's fair I think no you know I get
that
thank you very much because he tonight
is Canadian he thanked me for yeah very
appreciative of the opportunity to be on
the receiving end of the spaghetti okay
the other question is to tell us your
worst pan shooting story you don't use
three words or three small phrases mine
college jogging front lawn right which
is great one yeah should be updated like
there has to be is there a more recent
one they can do it right now but I I
think I keep burying them down this is
just my go-to and like maybe my boughs
are just so terrible all the time that
nothing stands out terrible experience
anymore I'm doing this is par for the
course now right I know my story school
okay primary school okay so like
Elementary yeah primary school toilet
that's good good thing someone saw doors
in Australia oh I wasn't in there we
need to know first one do you ever go
out of your way for free things like
free samples Oh a hundred percent yeah
of course that's one of the best parts
of my job is that I can get free [ __ ]
well do people send you weird free [ __ ]
now because she's sending it's kind of
just like you get you go to certain
events I was that Steve you and Steve
Zaragoza I got invited to an it's
experience kind of thing oh yeah he goes
all those all the things and it was a
while back and I was literally and I'm
not it's right next to my house
legitimately next to my building
connecting to my house that's nuts
I was just like oh I was having a drink
and I was came back home and I just
caught him on the way home so I was
complete happenstance I was like oh why
you here what are you doing yeah it's
like well I'm going here I was like well
I'm going there so what's that what's
here is like it's an it thing I was like
of course it [ __ ] [ __ ] can I come
please so I came he was like yeah sure
and they got the heaven steve was just
like so I only have one plus one and
Alana was there his girlfriend yeah and
but this isn't a camel ttyn he's in he's
in it yeah and she was like all right so
like stuff like that I just a yes sure I
mean even the the experience like the
big Hornet house they had on sunset and
Vine Steve got invited to that and he
was like you want to come I was like
sure I wasn't invited he's connecting
but so I went in with Steve and they did
the same thing he's like he's kind of in
it and it was like all right if you just
offered you some hair to make it look
like a mullet exactly like you remember
this guy with the mullet
but I got in there and like the director
was there I was like oh hey hey my oh
you didn't invite me I got in I cheated
machito my way and but yeah stuff like
that I cheat my way into a lot of things
I think that's I mean now's the time
hundred percent it'll fight off
eventually
someone's no who are you closest within
the it cast that's a good question
you know you'd expect it to be one of
the bullies because I mean we're
together every day on set but I probably
have to say Wyatt who plays Stan okay um
he's he lives in beli Hills his mom is
like my second mom here I used to when I
came here for like weeks at a time I'd
stay in the guest house and they're just
a very very nice human beings but yeah
so white white has helped me out with a
lot of sort of auditions and it's just a
very kind genuine human being and we
have I mean there's plenty of interviews
that we've said about each other was
just like um it was a it was doing build
the bill - yeah York and it was they
were just like oh yeah and the guy who
plays Henry Bowers is saying Wyatt's
house right now the interviewer was just
like what do you want to say - Nick Nick
right now do the Camrys like get out of
my house okay tell us a funny story
about your adorable dog Nick Oh a funny
story I mean she seems like she's
probably just cute she's literally she
does nothing wrong I wish there was she
was there was one time it's probably get
me in trouble with Peter or something
but I we had to get a passport like I
went to passport office something and
then I came back in the passport office
- way longer than I expected yeah so she
done multiple defecation zhan everything
but like stuff like that she doesn't
even she did that once and she was
looking at me just like I'm sorry I
didn't mean to I just had to go I
couldn't stop it no goose has done that
- like she punishes herself more than I
ever could for that situation it's like
understandable but it's like their their
ability to am oh I'm so sorry
to come out there was no you weren't
here yeah so she hasn't done that since
and I've left her for like I'll leave
her I mean I do a lot of auditions and
she still doesn't do anything just
there's literally no crazy stories
there's more like just cute videos I'll
tweet at some point I'm sure she looks
like a great little sweetheart what's
your do you do any sort of like pump up
for auditions I do listen to any sort of
specific songs you do any like routines
you know what I try to do is and this
just goes for life as well as auditions
yes I whatever I want to be whatever I
want to show - okay so if it's a comedy
audition in in the audition or if it's a
go to meet some friends like the value
of work and I want to be funny in front
of them yeah I listen to stand up and I
would stand up and stuff unlike the uber
driver there or whatever cool and for
some reason I've got a mind that kind of
just whatever I'm around moulds - yeah
you take it on which is great like
that's I was I was going on a first date
here one time and it was one of the best
first dates because I watched some
stand-ups I'm so charming yeah it's just
like and if I do if I have like a really
dramatic movie audition the next day or
like that that day then I try and do
some stuff that sort of makes me calm
and yeah I don't really have a routine
it's just kind of whatever is calm if I
surround myself with that I'll become
that's good that's more than I do I just
[ __ ] whale to some jock jams and
probably induces my anxiety okay
someone's asking which movie would be
better if we added Pennywise in it Oh
Schindler's List like two times we've
been seeing what I want to say penny
wise actually be funny I wanted to I
want to seem like a in like an Amy
Poehler Tina Fey Oh like yeah I mean I
in that vein I would love to see penny
wise and Mean Girls I think
right fantastic bingo I mean be the
meanest car be the meanest go he'd be
like you made it today Pennywise okay
someone's asking what projects do you
have coming up oh I have also if you're
taking a break or not no I well I do a
lot of I try to keep as busy as I can
otherwise you get lonely and depressed
of course so you I try to do movies and
TVs right now but also dumping into kind
of music and buy so I got a movie next
year that I'm shooting in May in Philly
I got danger-close that comes out in
November I'll never ever 8th here but
then I'm also going to New York to
record some stuff in the near future to
record music some music stuff yeah cool
yeah I mean that's always whenever I
went when I came here it was always like
whenever I go to LA whenever I move
there within that first year I need to
have record or something just so I can
have that that's my main goal like God
getting roles and jobs is a good thing
and if say if I got four things to this
wit this year and yeah couldn't do music
I'd be happy but my schedule this year
has allowed me to focus a lot on
originals and I have an EP sort of set
out that I can what can you tell us
what's sort of like what's a style that
you're leaning towards happy heard of
Jeremy Zuka nope he's like a very kind
of acoustic very chill music but it's
kind of that's mixed with kind of very
kind of Billy allas kind of cool minor
tones so it's a bit sad but it's also
very acoustic and kind of uplifting but
Sadler is like it's all yeah yeah I
can't wait I mean we all want to feel
sad and we all want to indulge in that
history right that's all Adele in Lana
Del Ray made their old gym yeah
something like that
but I'm very excited that's that should
be something that happens soon possibly
in the next month that I head over to
your can record stuff pocket and release
it whenever I want oh that's so exciting
okay last question he's such a squishy
baby boy did he have to work with anyone
to make those angry Henry faces an
American accent be so believable or is
that just raw Nick Talent
did you imagine if there was someone
that's if there's a psychopath in a
movie it's just like I'll call on the
psychopath fake face maker like so this
is how you make this face
just watch me no i watch with an accent
coach on my first american movie okay
and then very slightly on it
but by that point I'd done what it was
2017 2016 when we shot so I've been
doing American auditions for four years
at that point so it kind of kind of just
at that point been working on at this
point is kind of natural it's just yeah
when I first met you you were like I'm
lost rallying that's like I haven't
heard it you're like I'm masking it on
this okay actual last question do you
miss the mullet 100% really yeah it's a
dirty old rag of smelliness how did they
not as a rap present give you a lot more
so I wanted it apparently it's in like
the Smithsonian now here's hoping
no wait so are you gonna dabble with
some hair situation I want to I mean
this movie that I got coming up is a
play a real guy and back when the movie
is a person but he had a mullet when
like the events of the movie were
happening just like don't please please
don't put me in a mullet again you're
gonna be typecast adjust mullets I mean
not the worst thing in the world goes
not Nick thank you for being here so
much before you go everyone that is a
guest it makes time for us can say
personalized fortune cookie at us to
most of them so you can take a little
peek at what's inside fortune unless I
forget
Nicholas Hamilton equals a beautiful
girl direct quote from you that is true
is that from you yeah I did I did one of
the you know those whisper challenges
yeah he put headphones on and yet so
there was a the guy who said he said I'm
Nicholas Hamilton and I'm a beautiful
girl that's what you said right
that's one of my name's now which is
great oh I love it okay where can people
find you and everything you're doing if
they don't already know Nicholas Scott
Hamilton on Instagram I believe and Nick
underscore Hamilton with a no K on Nick
because that's incorrect there we go and
you can just go Hamilton on Twitter and
what you have is a music that will come
soon
I'm sure go watch it - got it - yeah
still in theaters end it - all of it all
of it thank you again this was super fun
we'll see you guys next time another
episode not too deep goodbye too deep
too deep deep deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer Melissa D
months camera operator Katrina Henning
edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]